bonsoir vous savez qu'on a beaucoup
parlé des pionniers de la télévision de
monsieur barthélémy qui est un monsieur
qui a beaucoup contribué au fait que
vous ayez maintenant chez vous un petit
écran et bien nous sommes nous également
au service de la recherche des pionniers
de la télévision et vous le voyez nous
ont des expériences de de tournage en
plein air parce qu'ils pensent que c'est
un petit peu plus vivant alors messieurs
vous mettez ça comme ça voilà on triera
ça par la suite je vous remercie mes
thèmes et des gens un peu partout parce
que c'est une fausse à courrier qu'on
est en train de préparer ici c'est pour
ça qu'on a construit des murs autour
voyez vous il ya quelques temps le
service de la recherche vous a présenté
une émission et cette émission c'était
les shadoks et immédiatement la france a
été divisé en deux ça a été une nouvelle
affaire dreyfus les gens envoyaient des
lettres il disait les shadoks et c'est
une émission immonde le dessin n'est pas
beau les auteurs sont des analphabètes
la moitié évidemment de ces lettres sont
des lettres pour l'autre moitié sont des
lettres compte
enfin toujours est il que nous avons été
inondé de courriers nous sommes ici
devant la maison de la radio et vous
voyez que tous ces locaux immenses qui
sont derrière sont remplies le capra qui
protestent contre les shadoks est
pourquoi nous avons décidé de faire une
émission sur le courrier de shadocks que
nous vous présentons tous les soirs mais
dans tout ce courrier il ya des tas de
gens qui disent qu'ils sont les ignobles
père
alors ces personnages doivent prendre
leurs responsabilités nous allons vous
montrer pour la première fois leur
visage se plaint jamais vous avez tout
d'abord à tout seigneur tout honneur
monsieur jacques rouxel qui est l'auteur
et le dessinateur des shadoks voyez que
c'est un sinistre personnage qui
dissimule sa fourberie derrière des
lunettes et les moustache épaisse
d'ailleurs cette fourberie dissimulé se
retrouve chez le musicien quand même
solal
il lui a non seulement une épaisse
moustache mais une barbe et en plus des
cheveux très très long ensuite nous
avons le réalisateur borg
il lui est enfin d'avoir un visage
ouvert et franc mais qui en réalité est
un personnage pervers également et le
dernier et monsieur claude piéplu claude
piéplu c'est la voix la voix horrible
des chaînes de petits provoqué des
protestations bien mais je ne vous en
dirai pas plus vous avez vu maintenant
les visages les silhouettes des auteurs
des shadoks vous allez revoir la
nouvelle série des shadoks qui sera
présenté sur sur cette chaîne tous les
soirs je crois et avec tout ce courrier
qui a été déversé ici par le service des
ptt voyez que c'est arrivé très
rapidement parce qu'il y avait des
timbres à 40 francs donc s'est livré à
domicile et dans les conditions les
meilleures
et tous les soirs vous verrez donc un
nouveau cette émission des
chefs-d'oeuvre avec le commentaire sur
le courrier des shadoks que votre
serviteur aura le plaisir et la hargne
de vous présenter
bof